foreign
24 on your Monday morning you know it's
not a competition to see which Nevada
Department of Transportation project is
going to drive you crazier
we've been talking a lot about the early
stages of the I-15 Tropicana rebuild but
there's something else you should know
about remember all the headaches of the
big squeeze and the 95 515 between the
spaghettiville and Eastern well welcome
to the sun of the big squeeze the lane
reductions construction cone mazes are
shifting to the 95 515 at Charleston a
lot of this project is going to be on
Charleston itself as ndot plans to widen
and rebuild the street on either side of
the freeway add more turn lengths from
Charleston to both directions in the 95
515 and a whole lot more yeah there is a
bilingual endot website where you can
keep up with the project sign up for
email or text updates as always the that
link is in the online version of this
story when you visit our website and
click on traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone you can join the driving
you crazy conversation at traffic eight
at eightnewsnow.com